we know that Trump supporters are
willing to commit great acts of heinous
violence in the name of trump how do we
know that because they did it on January
6 2021. and hundreds of their cases are
still being adjudicated and sentences
are being handed out so immediately the
concern has been
are they going to Riot tomorrow if Trump
is arrested are they going to Riot are
they going to protest Trump calling for
them to protest protest protest Trump's
saying it is time it is time to quote
take our nation back when his followers
try to take things it often gets very
very ugly Business Insider reporting
Trump issued a siren Call for his
supporters to protest and take our
nation back he made the call after
claiming without evidence that he will
be arrested Tuesday his lawyers said
they have no knowledge of the impending
arrest and increasingly there is this
question as to whether they will become
violent will they become violent the
Manhattan district attorney says and
this is weirdly cut off and I apologize
that attempt to intimidate his office
will not be tolerated after Donald Trump
calls for protest Alvin Bragg sought to
reassure staffers that they will indeed
be safe
here is my thought on this I am
maintaining cautious optimism that
Trump's followers won't Riot if he's
arrested
at least not in New York City they may
Riot somewhere but but at least not in
New York City and here's a couple
different logistical things
New York City is not a hotbed for Trump
support
icularly not Manhattan where presumably
this arrest and indictment will will
take place
um
many of these folks would have to go to
Manhattan in order to Riot in Manhattan
the site of Trump's arrest if it happens
there and quite frankly it's kind of
expensive to get over those bridges and
next thing you know they'll be paying
what 15 bucks to come into the City and
then 70 bucks to park during the day and
I I'm hoping quite frankly this may be
naive but I'm hoping that the financial
um element of this will be a deterrent
for them to come and actually protest
and become violent in Manhattan so first
of all hopefully that doesn't happen and
hopefully it doesn't happen at all now
that being said it is possible that they
will do something they may go to
Mar-A-Lago as a sign of support and so
hopefully like that wouldn't get violent
but of course going to Mar-A-Lago when
Trump's in New York for the arrest I
don't know is that maybe it's hard to
know what will sort of pacify these
folks maybe they will go to Washington
DC
not completely clear to me but I think
at this point I don't have too much to
say other than I hope and I'm cautiously
optimistic that there will not be
another horrifying anti-American
anti-democratic anti-law and Order day
of rioting like there was on January 6
2021 let me know in the comments on
Instagram on YouTube send an email info
davidpackman.com do you expect rioting
if Trump is arrested and if it happens
will Maga just say it wasn't them it was
BLM or some other Trope that they'll
pull out the way they did on January 6.
let me know what you think one of our
sponsors is Helix sleep I have been
sleeping on a helix mattress at home for
years now I couldn't be more happy with
it I recommend it to everybody the other
day even though she's not allowed in the
big bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it Helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position do you
get hot at night do you have back pain
and then Helix will match you with the
mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warranty unlike many
mattress companies all Helix mattresses
are made in the USA by a skilled
production team so you are supporting
good jobs helix sleep is giving my
audience up to 20 percent off plus two
free pillows what other mattress company
is going to give you 20 off go to Helix
sleep.com slash Pacman the link is down
below